this video was brought to you by
Innovative language which produces two
programs I recommend Romanian pod 101
and Italian pod 101 if you're learning
either Romanian or Italian visit the
link in the description to check them
out
as you probably know the romance
languages all developed from varieties
of Vulgar Latin that were spoken in
different parts of the Western Roman
Empire today they still have many
similarities and speakers of one romance
language can typically understand the
others to a limited extent whether in
speech or just in writing the romance
language that's often said to be the
hardest to understand for speakers of
other romance languages is Romanian at
least amongst the major romance
languages that might be partly because
of influence from neighboring languages
like Slavic languages and Hungarian and
you can see on the map that Romania is
geographically separated from other
romance-speaking countries Italian is
often considered the closest of the
major romance languages to Romanian but
just how similar are they let's listen
to a short sample of each language is
foreign
[Music]
super Mercato according to one
well-known study their lexical
similarity is 77 that means that 77 of
the words in either language have a
cognate an equivalent word of the same
origin in the other language some of
those words look and sound the same for
example the word for meat Italian versus
Romanian
others are close but slightly different
the words for forehead Italian
versus Romanian
the words for nose Italian
versus Romanian Nas the words for I
Italian versus Romanian okay but other
pairs of words have developed in
different directions and are less
recognizable as cognates belly button
Italian
umbelico versus Romanian both from Latin
umbilicus hey that sounds like umbilical
in umbilical cord Tahir Italian versus
Romanian
both come from Latin auride you can see
how either word developed from audire in
the Italian word the initial diphthong
became a simple u in the Romanian word
the final syllable was dropped in
Italian infinitive zendian
the usual endings for present
infinitives in Latin Romanian
infinitives don't have those endings if
we look here at the present tense
conjugations of both verbs we can again
see their different forms but we can
also see their similarity if we're
looking for it as we'll soon see in many
cases Italian uses one word of Latin
origin while Romanian uses a different
word of Latin origin rather than a
cognate but in other cases the
differences in vocabulary are due to the
more prominent use of loan words in
Romanian for example to think Italian
versus Romanian
alone word from Hungarian to live
Italian Vive versus Romanian
this is a loan word from common Slavic
or old church slavonic triati notice the
diacritics in the words
there are a number of letters in
Romanian with diacritics to distinguish
them from other vowels or consonants
Italian orthography doesn't have these
same diacritics a simple a is pronounced
ah as in Father this a with a circumflex
is pronounced like the second vowel in
the word roses this a with a brev is
pronounced ah like the a in a boat
there's also this vowel like an eye with
a circumflex it's also pronounced uh
today between then there's this s with
an under comma which is pronounced for
example which means fish in Italian this
sound is written with SC before I or e
meaning fish these diacritics can help
you immediately know you're looking at
Romanian when you see it the only
diacritics in modern Italian are the
acute accent and grav accent which are
used in certain cases like when the
stress falls on the final vowel City
grammar there are a few differences in
grammar between Romanian and Italian for
example case nouns in Romanians still
have three cases while in Italian and
most romance languages now in case
declensions are no longer used for
example the word for house in Romanian
is
articles while Italian has Standalone
definite articles that come before
announce Romanian doesn't instead the
suffix is at the end of nouns that
indicate case also indicate whether the
noun is definite or indefinite and they
also differ depending on gender speaking
of gender Latin has three genders
masculine feminine and neuter most
romance languages including Italian have
only two masculine and feminine but
Romanian has neuter as well there are no
separate forms for neuter nouns though
they behave like masculine nouns in the
singular and feminine nouns in the
plural
now let's look at some basic phrases in
both languages hi the way to greet
someone casually in Romanian is either
salute or while in Italian it's ciao
salute was borrowed from French but the
t is pronounced we'll see a number of
examples of Romanian vocabulary that
came from French like this
means good in its feminine form and it's
a short form of the somewhat more formal
greetings for specific times of day like
good day in Romanian it's
in Italian it's
a shortened form of buono mean good and
come from Latin bonus ziwa and Giorno
are cognates and both come from the
Latin word for day dies in a roundabout
way that I won't explain right now but
ziwa is feminine while Giorno is
masculine which is reflected in rather
than bun and Bun rather than Buona
how are you in Romanian fudge and in
Italian
these sentences look different but
speakers of either language can likely
make sense of the other the Romanian
sentence literally means what more you
do but it's a typical greeting which is
the equivalent of something like what
have you been up to it could also be
which means what are you doing but can
also be used as a greeting in Italian
one way to ask what are you doing is
kefai which is cognate with chefach but
in Italian that's not a usual greeting
the Italian greeting comestai literally
means how you are stai is a form of
stare which means to stay but also to be
in some contexts if translated directly
into Romanian this sentence could be
Kum is a cognate of kome and means how
is not a cognate of style but is a
cognate of the other verb meaning to be
in Italian which is say in the second
singular this also means how are you in
Romanian but not as a greeting it's used
when you're genuinely asking how someone
is doing and the answer is important to
you it's worth noting that the sentences
in both languages lack subject pronouns
both Romanian and Italian are pro-drop
the subject pronoun is not necessary
because we get that information from the
conjugated form of the verb
I'm fine thanks in Romanian
and in Italian
the first words
are cognates and both adverbs meaning
well as in I'm doing well the second
words meaning thanks are different in
Romanian it's the first person singular
present tense conjugation of the verb to
me it can mean to be thankful or content
and comes from the phrase
which means to many years and is said to
wish someone a happy birthday or happy
New Year the word for word translation
for that in Italian would be amultiani
though it's not used the second and
third words are clearly cognates though
she and a both mean and but she comes
from Latin seek meaning thus or in this
way while a comes from Latin ET in this
particular Romanian sentence she is
generally left out
the personal pronoun is obviously the
same
do you speak English in Romanian
and in Italian
again we see that both languages are
pro-drop the subject pronoun isn't
necessary
notice that the verb is different
Romanian is the second person singular
present conjugation of
which might come from the Latin word
which means word the Italian verb is the
second person singular present
conjugation of parlare which came from
Vulgar Latin parolare from Latin
Parabola meaning Parable or comparison
which was borrowed from ancient Greek
there are polite formal versions of
either sentence too
English
in Italian the polite second person
singular uses the third person
conjugation with the pronoun lay in
Romanian the third person is not used
rather there are special polite formal
pronouns the second person pronoun is
it used to be used just for second
person plural but it has mostly replaced
the old second person singular form too
it uses the second person plural
conjugation of the verb
another sentence have you been to France
in Romanian I forced in France and in
Italian
I is the second person present
conjugation of which means to have and
is used as the auxiliary verb in the
present perfect tense and other compound
tenses first means bean and is the past
participle of the verb Phi which means
to be Italian also uses a cognate of as
an auxiliary verb for most
verbsere meaning to be is the auxiliary
verb for a limited set of verbs
particularly those indicating presence
or movement and that's the case here say
is the second person singular present
tense of essere and it's used here with
Stato which means bean and is the past
participle of the verb the other verb
meaning to be actually starto is the
past participle of both verbs a note
about first and it's infinitive fee it
may seem like this verb has no
connection to either of the Italian
verbs meaning to be but they're actually
connected the Latin verb for to be some
and Essay in its infinitive was a
supplative verb meaning that it actually
incorporates forms from two different
verbs just like English were and B
originally came from different verbs
Italians say and essere developed from
one of the two verbs while Romanian
first and fee developed from the other
one which was used in Latin for perfect
tenses the supplative verb is still used
in both languages but its two component
verbs appear in some different forms
both un and in come from Latin in France
and francha both come from Latin frankia
but Romanian Franza was born from French
France
another sentence where's the police
station in Romanian
and in Italian
we can see quite a few differences in
these sentences the first words meaning
where are different and developed from
different Latin words comes from Latin
meaning whence or from where Dove is an
abbreviated form of Dove which comes
from Latin de Ubi meaning from plus
where next we see the verbs meaning to
be in the third person singular present
form Yes
actually in Romanian there are two
possible forms
that form is somewhat more like the
Italian one the
nounsione both mean station the Romanian
word is a long word from Russian which
came from French section which came from
Latin sectio which has the accusative
form sectionem and means cutting off
again note that in the Romanian now
definiteness is shown in the inflection
ah while the Italian noun has a definite
article in front of it the Italian words
developed directly from a Latin word
statio which has the accusative form
status and means Outpost or station
Romanian day and Italian D both mean of
and come from Latin de the words for
police
both come from Latin polytia meaning
state or government which ultimately
came from ancient Greek politea meaning
polity citizenship or government but the
Romanian word entered the language from
French
now let's look at one more sentence and
this time something a little different
for the final breakdown we're going to
focus on the first sentence of the
universal Declaration of Human Rights in
either language in English they
translate to all human beings are born
free and equal in dignity and rights in
Romanians
and in Italian
is the nominative feminine plural of
from Latin
is the masculine plural of Tutto which
traces back to the same word in the two
words that mean beings again we see the
supplative verb to be that developed
from two different verbs
beings okay this one takes a minute to
explain
is the plural of the feminine noun with
a definite article attached it comes
from meaning to be plus a suffix that
forms abstract nouns s city is the
plural of the masculine noun a verbal
noun which comes from the verb essere
again note that the Italian noun is
preceded by a definite article while the
Romanian noun has a nominative ending
that also shows the noun is definite and
umani both mean human but umane is the
nominative feminine plural of Oman while
umani is the masculine plural of Umano
and nascono both men are born but in
Romanian it's reflexive without the
reflexive pronoun it means to give birth
to to say to give birth to in Italian
there's an idiom
literally give to the light rather than
the
verbi both mean free but since they
agree with the noun Libre is the neuter
plural which is feminine in form of
Liber while libery is the masculine
plural of libero again we see the words
for and but this time the Italian word
is Aid rather than a Ed is the form used
before vowels and a is the form used
before consonants
more commonly both mean equal and come
from Latin aquales the Romanian word is
actually alone from French egal
and in both mean in of course and come
from Latin in as we've seen before
and and dinita both mean dignity and
come from Latin dignitas or its
accusative form dignitatim again we see
the words for and she and a and finally
the words meaning rights
is the plural of dripped and diriti is
the plural of dirito both of which come
from Latin directus an adjective meaning
laid straight or upright in both
Romanian and Italian these words can
function as an adjective meaning
straight or right in both the senses of
correct and direction or side or as a
noun meaning right
as you can see Romanian and Italians
share a lot of similarities as pairs of
romance languages in general do in many
pairs of sentences the words are mostly
cognates while in other cases the words
came from different Roots but still
Latin roots and in other cases there are
lone words though in the examples in
this video we didn't encounter a large
number of them not by choice that's just
how it worked out what I often hear from
native speakers is that they can
understand the other language fairly
well in writing and whether they can
understand it in speech depends on
exposure and many people say that they
can learn to converse comfortably in the
other language in a matter of weeks with
constant practice and exposure the
verdict Romanian and Italian are closely
related and fairly similar but
definitely not similar enough for their
speakers to communicate well without
learning the other language the question
of the day for speakers of Romanian and
Italian how similar are the two
languages in your experience can you
understand the other language and to
other people how similar did Romanian
and Italian seem to you
if you're learning either Romanian or
Italian be sure to check out our
sponsors courses Romanian pod 101 and
Italian pod 101 which I've linked to
down in the description these pod 101
courses are a great way to get started
with the language as they follow a clear
progression from beginner to Advanced
but you also have a lot of control over
which language functions and features
you want to focus on within each level
give them a try with a free lifetime
account and if you like them and upgrade
to a paid plan then that really helps
out the Lang Focus channel so it would
be great if you check them out it's time
to say thanks to all of the langfocused
patreon supporters especially these ones
right here on the screen they are the
top tier patreon supporters so many
extra special thanks go out to them
check out patreon.com langfocus to find
out how you can become a patron as I
mentioned earlier I've compared several
pairs of romance languages on this
channel check out this playlist of
romance language comparisons I'm sure
you'll find them even more fascinating
than this video